germany is looking for gas with russia
severely lowering deliveries norway and
qatar
jumped in but with many looking
anxiously towards heating season norway
says it cannot increase its gas supplies
to germany it already delivers or
delivers all the gas it can that's
according to prime minister jonas
gastera
during a press conference which he held
with the german chancellor olaf schultz
in oslo any further boost would
necessitate new gas discoveries
previously qatar announced that it
cannot deliver more gas either
now the fallout from russia's war in
ukraine has pushed gas prices in europe
to new records future contracts trading
in amsterdam
saw sharp increases when russia invaded
ukraine back in february
and more hikes when it reduced
deliveries to european countries now
last year russian imports accounted for
more than half of gas deliveries to
europe with almost a third of gas demand
coming from the industry
and just over 40 percent from households
political leaders in berlin say they are
doing what they can to replace russian
gas with renewable energies
but that'll take time last year russian
gas deliveries accounted for almost 500
million gigawatts hours of energy so far
this year only three and a half thousand
gigawatt hours were added in solar and
only one and a half thousand in wind
energy
so let's get carol nachla's view on this
she is the head of the advisory firm
crystal energy uh welcome to dw carroll
germany is trying to transition away
from russian gas
by the looks of it the country still has
quite a way to go what do you think
absolutely i mean it's not easy if it
was for example oil or coal you would
have found it may be a faster solution
but gas by its nature is a long-term
business you rely on pipeline gas which
took decades to build and to be
functioning and to be filled up so it's
not something that can happen overnight
i know that germany is working very hard
on reducing its consumption of natural
gas and particularly of natural gas
coming from russia and they have done
you know significant uh progress today
but to say it's going to turn its back
entirely on it it's not just germany
many european countries and many
countries around the world as well it's
going to take a while this is the
reality of the gas business
unfortunately so even with the political
motivation uh to turn away from russian
gas germany will still need uh kremlin
approved gas in the future for that
matter
well in the future again this is the
question of time so in the future the
longer term there's plenty of gas around
and not necessarily coming from russia
it just takes time to take that gas out
of the ground put it you know even
pipeline or on ships like lng they could
find natural gas you do have available
but it just takes time to build the
terminals to export it and even if they
are there you need the terminals to
import it and that's what you don't have
in german this is going to be built but
when you have more energy coming to
germany then you don't really need
russian gas you can do it easily without
russian gas but that will take time
now there are people who are fearing a
gas shortage when it comes uh to heating
season in in the coming months
not only in germany but in other
countries in europe as well should it
come to that who should be prioritized
companies or households
well look it's a question of balancing
economics with morality and political
interest but usually i think most
governments would agree that households
should be given the priority and then
industries will have to cope even the
economic cost might be much more
significant but if i were to answer it
from a moral perspective i would say
households should come first
big efforts are underway in europe as i
mentioned to move away from russian gas
but if we look at other parts in the
world what does the picture there look
like
well it seems that you see it's very
variable because in the u.s for example
we have with the biden administration
they are going quite aggressively on
climate change but in the last bill that
they passed inflation reduction act we
can see that they are almost giving
similar treatment to green energy and
electric vehicles as also conventional
oil and gas asia is pretty hardcore they
will stick to fossil fuel for as long as
it takes because they put great emphasis
on energy security quite rightly so
because i think what europe came to
realize after this energy crisis is that
you cannot really separate between
climate security and energy security and
focus only on climate security we cannot
achieve climate security climate targets
without meeting the requirements of
energy security first and that's what
we're seeing today in europe a more
leniency towards investments in gas for
example that's why gas has been
classified as a green investment in in
the eu following the crisis
uh carol briefly if you could um
how long will it take for a highly
industrialized nation like germany to
move away
from fossil fuels to become independent
from fossil fuels
well it will take a while it will take
really decades and not years
carol notley founder and ceo of advisory
firm crystal energy carol thank you for
your time
thank you